what want to go around that love let's
dive into that one right love it's very
general its be more specific so in an
aspect of love or something like that
sex is an aspect of love cool so it mean
really you know you can tell the lady
was like love and the guy was like sex
and that's really where the genders
differ tell you what ante won't even
come to you yet mate unless that was a
heckle in which case no so how would I
even entertain that
I'll just go no okay so love love and
sex and the kind of tension between
those in a relationship I like that
that's a good topic let's come to this
kind of like wedge here what you want to
hear a rapper Yorkshire pudding I mean
technically it's a food but it is a
pretty obscure specific food so I'm
happy to take that love and sex and the
tension between them Yorkshire pudding
you never have it Yorkshire pudding
don't worry I'll explain it middle of
the room here kind of what you want to
wrap up what was that gnomes yeah I like
it I like gnomes I was doing a gig in
Little Rock Arkansas I was talking about
genetics cuz I'd have my own my 23andme
done
I mentioned the human genome someone
goes what's a genome and his friend next
one
you stupid it sits on your lawn with a
fishing rod so
you know a lesser comedian would have
saved that joke and worked in a bit
later on so it would seem like I'm real
smart but I'm honest upfront so we have
loved sex and the tension between
Yorkshire pudding gnomes thank you let's
come to this line here which one ratbat
a Clockwork Orange the Anthony Burgess
novel Stanley Kubrick film a Clockwork
Orange yeah see you will you were like
you won't know this yeah I did [ __ ] off
I've already as well I've already it's
hard because it's not really written in
English and he doesn't ever translate
you just try and absorb have you read it
yeah so suck it I'm sorry you that was a
really good suggestion and then I've
just been coming like yeah mmm I know
all about it
okay so we have love sex and the tension
between them Yorkshire pudding gnomes or
Clockwork Orange find all a section over
here what you want to hear rapper
pickles it's a food any any raised on
pickles not any raise on it
snorkels cool pickles nor calls is the
suggestion we'll combine them to make
that more original so love sex and the
tension between them Yorkshire pudding
gnomes are Clockwork Orange and pickles
knuckles this then lovely people of the
Comedy Cellar Lord treat to close out
the night little thing called a
freestyle rap that has a rap made up on
the spot based in town in those
suggestions it's not prepared it's not
written I do not worry or not anywhere
near as bad as you are expecting a
privately educated middle class white
boy to be let's drop that beat my friend
let's have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm excited for this and thank you for
the chairs over there yeah you can do
this grass in the garden or home of
either side of the path a laugh of my
gnome looking so funny I say what is it
basically a cross of a smurf and a
[ __ ] little red hat and a fishing rod
I really find it weird right by the
wishing pond it's like I'm wishing well
you can drop a coin in and get a lot of
good luck I'm purloined in any nose that
I see in the gravel driveway to pick it
up scroll away to put it down my way put
it in my hands maybe put it on the blimp
if I'm not the ceramic cup you know it
goes ding here is flashes into seizes
smashes on the tarmac see a little known
with his weird Papa Smurf that is okay I
take the Papa Smurf back to the gnome of
endeavor form a proper cap in my ass a
look from a tower like a princess to Bob
Fosse a brave damn Prince and a breach
in love I let my hair down he tugs on
and he climbs and then he says princess
you want to recline I'm like wait after
love what happens next
he says I thought it's obvious we're
gonna have sex and I say no please way
if we gotta establish a relationship
yeah I chewed an approach to lovemaking
[ __ ] guys like no I do it my way fast
like a highway screw any foreplay
I just want to go down right there when
it comes to love yeah I really don't
care calm her down flame in like I'm a
comment the lover hey here is the type
that is platonic move on next in I'm
gonna talk your teacher how I went in
the coast of the snorkel some people
like to see me flow along the Humber
that's a river so I can add vinegar
cucumber pickle live in the tiny little
jar I've got the best painters by far
and move along people look at me so
strange as I quote from a clockwork
already
yeah the literary Norwich you know what
deserve this I'll be reading that novel
by the Anthony Burgess the main
character had all of those urges italic
so they said you know what Beethoven's
3rd this pan is fit I'll try and
simplify it's a music horn and a
symphony they hold its eyes open he says
oh wow portrayed head to lead by Malcolm
McDowell in the movie banned in the UK
last in is a food what'd you say I'm
gonna mix up a batter happen at ER with
my Nana put it in the oven 50 minutes
never goes to plan cuz the [ __ ] I cook
it in is not hot enough it doesn't rise
high it's rotting off the edges it looks
like a flat pancake and the Yorkshire
man would know that mistake you've got
apples up over top to the highest
temperature get the heat like we drop
the Rams in here I like to eat that food
keep myself good-looking cuz there's
very few calories in the Yorkshire
pudding
[Music]